if you have a nose like me you might
think surely the size of those colossal
nostrils doesn't need more assistance in
cavernous opening them up requires you
to put a land registry down so that you
can walk through you have to get a
planning permission
did you have to get one for Arab size
noses yeah you have to take your
ethnicity as you uh as you select the
order icons out if you're joking are you
joking I mean how racist would that be
I didn't think on this episode of life
hacks I would be the only one here
without a pack of nasal strips to hand
good face Chris that's the that's the
makeup face there it is
familiar with this life hacks it's the
longest series that we've done on Modern
wisdom tools techniques and tactics for
productive and efficient life we do a
round table each of us proposes
something that we've fallen in love with
over the last few weeks about how to
create a perfect toasted sandwich or get
out of a parking fine or a brand new
seat that you can sunbathe in
appropriately naked while your neighbors
can't see whatever it is and then the
other two will critique or go and buy it
immediately on Amazon links to
everything we talk about are in the show
notes below and as is tradition even in
2023 uh Jonathan there is a hot potato
for you there my friend what have you
got life hacks wise those fake life
hacks that you just reeled off sound all
sounded fantastic we should I know you
did one about toasted sandwich you did
one about how to create the perfect
toasted sandwich two and a half years
ago yeah my God I can't even remember my
own life I should maybe go back and be
like wow what a great idea yeah exactly
um so my first one well
you might you'll probably want to change
what I say when I say this based on an
email I received from you very recently
I was gonna say given the time of year
given what everybody will be doing given
it's the first one it's what everyone
listens to the
some sort of annual review process so
we've all used the Chris Sparks annual
review but I believe Chris
do you have your own now I have taken a
uh Menage à trois from a bunch of
different uh productivity things David
perrell Chris Sparks was heavily
influential uh some stuff from the six
minute diary some other [ __ ] that I
picked up online uh and yeah if you want
to go and get that you can go to Chris
willx.com review uh it is not too late
to do an annual review even though it's
the start of January uh you can go and
do that it'll help you to go back over
here last year and set goals for the new
one but yes 100 doing an annual review
uh super super important why do you do
yours
I think they're well I think everybody
tries to say go people try to set like
resolutions and goals and things like
that I think the review process
um some of the questions that that I
that I like going over the most are like
what are the what things in the year
make you most happy what things in the
year did you enjoy doing the most who
did you like spending time with the most
and then almost sticking those things in
your calendar straight away so like
trips away places you went
um Hobbies you picked up things you
stopped doing it's just such an easy way
like things you would maybe if you don't
have a time to sort of sit and formally
look back on a period of time and think
you know what should I do more of the
lessons back in again you can sometimes
go years and think like oh yeah remember
when I used to I remember when we did
that that was really good fun we should
do it again so that that sort of process
looking through your camera reel when
you're doing it looking through your
calendar when you're doing it
um looking through message history and
stuff with people
um always to bring up prompts that you
would maybe just they would just drift
into your past and you'd forget and then
doing that before you set any goals or
targets or
um resolutions for the year really
helpful but I think following something
that's guided specifically that's the
reason I mentioned it so I think sitting
with a blank document and reviewing your
year very difficult to do having kind of
guided questions or prompts
very very useful so there's a section
that I stole from David perel that goes
in the the review that I talked about
where he he has a favorite memory
favorite new city favorite new song
favorite live show favorite sex like
favorite interaction with an animal like
like not the same thing yeah perhaps you
don't know but having that down is just
especially after you accumulate a few
years of those there's things that
you'll definitely have forgotten that
you've done and you go back and you go
[ __ ] remember when we did that thing and
I fell in love with Zeus for six months
I think that's the key you know that you
said Johnny about things Fading Into the
the murky past and then you look back oh
yeah like this is why you just gotta
write stuff down and there's there's no
there's nothing that will substitute for
just physically going through a process
and writing it down otherwise like if
you just think oh yeah my goal is this
guarantee in a year's time you'll have
forgotten that it was even a goal and
you end up with one of two situations
either you've totally smashed the goal
and you look back on it and you're like
wow I can't believe that was actually
something I really wanted to hit and now
I've blasted straight past it because it
seems so mundane and if you just said
that verbally you would have forgotten
and you would have wouldn't really felt
like there was much progress or you set
the goal and you didn't get anywhere
near it and you look back and you go um
for having not done anything to move
towards that goal right that's refocus
let's do it properly this year the other
reason that you've got to do the review
first before you set the goals is the
goals manifest they grow out of the
review right if you end up setting a
bunch of goals that help you to achieve
a thing which this year you looked back
on and reflected as a negative
experience like I hate my time working
on statistics and I want to move more
into the creative realm my goal for next
year is to get another Statistics
qualification because you haven't
realized that statistics makes you
miserable you end up circling this sort
of uh liminal Purgatory of always doing
the same thing badly
and I think like the whole 80 20
analysis of why things are good or why
things are bad let's say you've had a
really good year in your career for
example one of the questions in
um the review I was doing was saying
like which habits do you think if
something's gone well which habits do
you think we're responsible for that
which actions we're responsible for that
and when you really sit and think about
it it's usually stuff that you're like
oh yeah it's probably just this what was
yours
so things like
um consistent sleep routine like this
year because I've been over to the us a
couple of times and had my sleep like
forced out of a rhythm for a few times I
think realizing that
um the days where I've struggled in
general with anything like training
productivity concentration anything it's
just when my sleep is
um thrown out such as the con I know
it's such a it's like grandparent style
advice isn't it like get get your eight
hours in but I think just a reminder
that like when things have gone well for
me this year my sleep's been really
really good nice um for example uh Yusuf
where you go
you are you might not be able to see it
there see that little white box in the
background yes what is it leaning
against the other white box yeah which
is also a life hacker what's the first
one first white box is a red light
therapy box so that's from a company
called block blue light
um we have a we have a discount code as
well which is just propane but it's a
way to offset the something you you just
mentioned before we started Chris which
was that it's 2 30 and it's starting to
get dark in December in the north of
England so
this is not quite a sad lamp it's the
other spectrum of red light uh which you
can't you only get from sun exposure it
doesn't turn you it has a completely
different mechanism of action these
boxes do both red and infrared
and I recently did a review looking at
how it affected my blood parameters my
inflammatory markers my immune markers
and all that stuff
um and surprisingly because it seemed
really gimmicky and really biohacky
to China red light box but the data is
actually really compelling uh and
there's just multi-system benefits
across immune endocrine mood Muscle
Recovery just so much stuff from red
light therapy buying a box is way more
cost effective than going to a clinic
that does red light therapy for 70
pounds a session or something because
that thing costs about three four
hundred pounds
and it'll obviously last you forever so
by the time you've had five treatments
you've broken even so I think in terms
of easy win red light box is the one
what's your protocol for using it
10 minutes front and back
so you there's different protocols
depending on the strength of the the
light and how far away from you sitting
and how deep the tissues are that you
want to treat so there's lots of
variables to play around with I've got a
kind of a rough guideline on the video
as well but there's a book by Ari
Whitton who goes deep with it like
really what's the tldr just tell us the
the tldr is 10 minutes front and back I
think unless you've got a particular
area that you're looking to treat and
then then you've got to consider like
distance and wavelength and power
transfer and all that stuff why use a
red light lamp and not a sad lamp side
lamp different mechanism so should you
be using both can you get something is
there such a red light and sad coming
out for the people that don't know
that's seasonal affective disorder lamp
it's like a super bright Lumen thing
that's supposed to give you that's more
circadian rhythm melatonin cortisol
mechanism right yeah so that that's more
to wake up in the morning so if you if
you went like if you're living somewhere
in like Finland or Iceland or something
and you go out and there's just barely
any sun
then you might you might need a side
lamp but generally sad is on the blue
light spectrum and I think we're already
getting more than enough blue light from
staring at screens all day so personally
that's not something I would invest in
um and then red light therapy is less to
do with circadian regulation as more the
kind of other benefits that you get from
from it's
cellular hormesis melatonin mediated
effects what did your blood markers say
to be honest they went from normal to
normal which I'm quite pleased about
there are people who have in the data
there's dysfunctional thyroid that have
that has normalized and actually people
coming off thyroxine entirely which I
think is insane from using red light
therapy on the thyroid from in sort of
targeted way my inflammatory markers
went down a little bit I think my
testosterone went up slightly but not
not enough for me to say oh yeah it was
definitely that that caused that I also
heard that certain types of red lamps
don't actually produce the right type of
red light I'm gonna guess that you've
checked to make sure that the particular
brand that you're using isn't just a red
bulb that yeah that's a very good point
so there are there's a lot of cheap red
light boxes that just shine a red light
and you think oh yeah that'll do but
there's only the specific wavelengths
and power levels that you need and a lot
of the Chinese manufacturers will just
produce something that looks looks like
it's good and sell it for cheap the
manufacturer of this guy had a long long
chat with him and podcast where he goes
into the process and the the different
kind of testing kits that he's got at
home to when he goes to China and Taiwan
and and kind of discusses the specific
specifications that he wants over the
the bulbs and make sure that they are
within the therapeutic range
very nice just to add it's something
that so it sounds pretty woo-woo doesn't
it like it doesn't it sounds a bit
strange sitting in front of a red light
I have been doing it but I do 20 minutes
all all on my front because I can't be
bothered to turn around halfway
um it just feels nice so I just do it
while I meditate in the morning
like sort of technical benefits aside I
think if something feels nice
and it's a pleasant thing to do it makes
you feel good afterwards you probably
keep doing it
um you know when you sat in front of an
open fire yeah a similar feeling it
feels really like wholesome it's I mean
it's the same thing like open fires
radiate red and infrared as well
fantastic
I've got something down there I can't
see what it is no not the [ __ ] Goose
on the bed I've got a red light over
there uh I gotta I got a pocket one
um which is three by four so it's only
like he would be able to carry it in a
bag uh and I really enjoyed that as well
sitting down and just having that on me
so I'm all for trying it uh what's the
company that you suggested and what's
the code block blue light and the code
is propane cool so and what's that get
you off
that's like I see 10 10 off I believe so
there's they have a UK and a US New
Zealand Australia website it's the same
company a while ago I mentioned I bought
some red light glasses that worked same
same Brands if you want to pick some
pick up some of those that actually work
as well they are the same it's the same
manufacturer cool all right so my one uh
this I used while I was in Vegas the
other week and it is remember the
server's name so the server will always
come over and introduce themselves or
they'll usually have a name badge on and
it just makes such a difference being
able to shout your server's name across
a crowded room means and using it
consistently as well thank you Brittany
or thank you whatever it is means that
you're gonna get served first you're
going to probably get your drinks
brought over uh and make sure it's going
to be in the nicest glasses make sure
it's going to be using you know
everything is going to be done to a
better standard if you remember their
name it means that you can get their
attention when you need to check when
you need to do whatever and it just
actually feels quite polite so I just it
shocked me how much I hadn't bothered to
remember the server's name and it also
shocked me how much of a difference it
made in a crowded Las Vegas strip Hard
Rock Cafe at 8pm at night on a Saturday
it surprised me how much of a difference
it made so remember the server's name
nice how how much has your attitude to
tipping changed since you've gone
Stateside yo strong armed into it
frankly it's a struggle session and I
mean I I once went to a venue where I
tipped the serving girl I want to say 15
on a pretty large bill so there's maybe
15 on a 50 Buck round of drinks and she
looked at the paper
printed a new receipt out turned it back
around pushed it toward me and said
let's try that again shall we wow like
she was quite she was quite sassy so it
was like funny or whatever in any case
but uh yeah that that happened so even
with a high sassometer that is cheeky so
that's through the roof man yeah but
it's it is what it is it's already a tip
then is it it's 15 they're like oh no
that's not good enough sorry then why
how is it optional well they'll do a lot
of the time now they have these iPads
that pivot two ways so the iPad is both
the till for the server to use and this
is the same in Starbucks in a bunch of
you know whatever restaurant or quick
use Cafe during which the serving staff
have had zero input to do with the
creation or service of your food they've
put it into a bag it's like look if you
heat up a toasty do I is that five
percent is that ten percent but they'll
flip it over and on it there's preset
levels sometimes like 15 20 25 custom
and
I they preset the numbers so if it
starts 20 25 30. you go well if I go
into custom and then say nothing and
then usually there's a queue with people
behind you that can all see over your
shoulder at what you're about to press
then you've got to sign your energy
faster than you are yeah exactly I hate
it I need to pay like don't give me
options
look it is what it is Johnny what you
got okay
um I was just thinking about my my
tipping experience in Hawaii it's very
very similar what happened
well just just that the the iPad thing
like the fixed I don't remember that
being a custom option so I can remember
standing in an airport in Hawaii
paying 50 for two like paninis and two
coffees in this in the Starbucks because
it was the only place to get breakfast
so you're fifty dollars at 50 Quid in
basically at that point and then they
twizzle the iPad and go how much would
you like not would you like to tip how
much would you like to tip you think can
getting emotionally blackmailed into
paying more
Yeah It's just tough
um so this one is something I've been
doing with training recently
um and it's something I've just found
kind of my training's been very like
bodybuilding focused like not powerless
thing anymore really
um and I find like doing
three four sessions a week the same
routine every week a little bit dull
um so I took a four session program and
this is not really really a life hack
but it's it's been really interesting
for me it's made training more fun I
take four sessions a week of a trading
split and do but I only train three
times a week so every week is different
like it rotates it every week so every I
think it's like a month to do the full
cycle
um that's helpful and secondly if you've
been training a while
um like more than a couple of years you
love everybody's run into that problem
where you can only do an exercise for
like three four times before you're just
running up against like hitting the same
reps in the same load and it's very very
hard to progress so taking something and
spreading of like eight nine ten days
extends that cycle and makes it slightly
easier to eat a little bit more out of a
training program so you can do it
obviously with anything right so five
days into four four days into three
three days into two whatever you want to
do are you actually compressing the days
down or of a four day split are you only
doing three which means that the
following week it's back legs and chest
and then the week after that is arms
back and legs yeah so week one is like
ABC week two is d a b yes Etc yeah
um and it just keeps it interesting
because it fit every week even though
it's because you know you kind of build
that Association of like well Monday is
the day when I do like bench and then
cable fly and then that no longer exists
so each each week you're doing a
different combination tiny change
um but has quite a big effect I found
like recovery progression keeps it
interesting nice I like
that totally free as well
Seth
this one is from
Alice doctor Alice the volcanologist
which is
to eat the most boring meal of the day
post-workout
so the day where
you you've got the most
points to spend
should the the meal where you've got the
most points to spend should should
really be like the evening where you can
enjoy it socially usually a post-workout
meal is kind of a
it's just a utility meal so have the
most boring meal of the day there where
you you check all of your nutritional
boxes
to save some some of the fun calories
for later
would there not be an argument that if
you're eating you should try and avoid
any of the meals being boring that you
don't need to necessarily have boring
nutritional meals
sometimes it's unavoidable if you if you
see your your total examples of a kind
of meal that is unavoidably boring
he's just having to defend the life hack
that isn't it it's not even mine you
submitted it you submitted it you want
to stand up for this lady true someone
who if you've got micronutrient targets
or certain vegetable intake or something
the other way to think of it though is
you say is to if you're going to play
around with the goal posts is to say
just train before you go out for a
social meal and then
you can have an exciting social meal
with the most calories in post-workout
um
what are you doing diet at the moment
Johnny
what am I doing with it
what'd you mean are you try are you
tracking anything oh yeah so I'm I'm
trying to to get down to 89 kilos from
94. so I kind of done my my weight loss
in two phases with phase one was when I
was like 105 took it down to 95 and as I
write I'm done with dieting for a while
so from like July of this year just
passed or last year if you listen to
this up to now and then I'm going to try
and get down to sub 90. Jesus yeah you
should be quite lean at sub 90. but uh
that involves tracking which actually
links to one of my
I've got one that I've been playing
around with since I've been in Austin
and it's have multiple gym memberships
so I'm spoiled for choice in Austin with
like on it Training Center Atomic
athlete
um lift ATX tons of gold gyms all over
the place there's this place called Los
campiones which is like a uh Dream Land
for lifting in and most of them in big
cities at least that I've seen in
America that are quite competitive like
this are about 40 bucks so it's maybe 40
or 50 bucks to get a good membership at
one of these spit and sawdust style
bodybuilding type gyms and my current
Armory setup of gyms is uh one with very
broad open and close times so that's the
commercial gym usually for me that's a
gold uh it's also the one that's got the
quietest
atmosphere it means I can go in and do
listen to stuff prep for work usually
episodes while I'm in their training
then I've got one that I can go and
train with my boys which is lift ATX
that's spitting sawdust gangster rap and
Slipknot and that's like a really cool
very social open gym that's good and
then the final one is a gym that has
group classes if I need to externalize
motivation and that's on it at the
moment our Atomic athlete would be
another one you don't need to have this
entire like Armory portfolio of gyms but
it is good to have at least two I think
Dean has had this problem since he's
been back in Newcastle he's between
Newcastle and Middlesbrough and he's
training at Reebok CrossFit hindsight
which a year ago he loved and now he's
bored of and he wants to go somewhere
new but a year ago he really loved
Reebok CrossFit tyneside and a lot of
people I think have fallen out of love
with their training when what they've
done is fallen out of love with the gym
you just need to be in a new environment
with new music different machines
different people to talk to different
routes to get there and you would be
surprised how much extra energy you can
inject into your training if you just
train in a new location
I like the different moods of workout as
well where you've got the set type of
session where you just need to get it
done you've got other stuff on your mind
and then you've got like the social
session and so being able to choose that
it's a lot to coordinate but
you can see the utility in it what does
your training look like if you've got
like
it sounds almost like different trading
modalities as well yeah it is but I it's
just moving as much as I can getting as
much sunlight as I can not trying to
stick to any one program too rigidly and
just enjoying training and stuff so
mostly bodybuilding style things some
high intensity stuff and then two
sessions of pickleball a week for kind
of outright cardio and then sitting on
the exercise desk when I can when I
remember it is the goal just
enjoy it be healthy like yeah be healthy
enjoy it put on a good bit of size with
Zach throughout the back end of this
year doing bro splits in lift but we
both started to just get a bit lethargic
and
training got a little bit boring so
we've now added in these group classes
on it a little bit this is
post-menopausal symptoms oh again yeah
you might vacillate back and forward you
know I become pre-menopausal again and
then I go back through it all over again
I saw you doing some incline bench with
Ollie from Bring Me The Horizon did do
some incline bench with olive I was
pretty impressed I think you're doing
like 100 100 kilos or so
100 pounds
oh was it it'll be pounding
definitely not 100 kilos 100 kilos per
arm
no on an incline barbell bench oh yeah
yeah yeah
see you waiting 100 kilos I was yeah
I think that's pretty good Chris thank
you thank you we have been lifting a lot
this year we put on a lot of size this
year just eating but eating like an
[ __ ] as well just eating everything
inside like constant desserts it's not
been the highest quality calories so I'm
gonna try and dial that back in this
year there's a real difficulty I have
blending the mental sharpness I get from
intermittent fasting with the
lack of physical degradation that I get
from having like regular meals that are
of high quality throughout the day I
find it very difficult to maintain a
good physique whilst doing anything
close to a hard intermittent fast well
Chris have you thought about having your
most boring meal of the day
he's got you there I knew he's gonna
come full circle eventually right
Jonathan Johan what have you got get us
uh so it's a it's a triple triple
pronged hack which is three things in
unison I think I've meant well two of
them would definitely be mentioned
before uh so the first one is something
that I actually heard on Modern wisdom
recommendation from
Derek Moore played more dates which is
to take like a standard day of eating so
it's the setup you would normally have
on like a regular day plug it into
something called chronometer which is an
app that's iOS Mac app I'm sure it
exists for Android as well
um and it just scores you based on your
micronutrient profile so just as an RDA
percentage where are you sure on like
vitamin c a d k Etc it is extremely
difficult to get anywhere close I don't
know whether anyone's ever tried this
before is some of Yusuf and I've spoken
about way harder than you'd think to do
that
um the thing however it's so cool to see
it so you put in your normal food intake
for the day and then it's got like
pre-saved it's got um
quite a few popular supplement Brands so
you'd plug in an athletic green serving
and everything goes from being like
five percent ten percent ten percent to
like 300 300 300 so first one at first
hack is that is like if you are trying
to improve your diet in the new year
which so many people do
um I do think it's important to look at
the macronutrient and the micronutrient
profile
stick your diet stick an average day
into chronometer and see where you fall
second thing is athletic greens still
using it which is a hell of a testament
and then the third thing which is
another tip that um I gave a while ago
which is something else I'm still using
over a year later is macro factor for
tracking macros
um that app is getting better every I
mean they've just done another update
um the guys behind that really know what
they're doing and with MyFitnessPal just
adding some making some features premium
um if you're finding that annoying like
the barcode scanner it now being a
premium feature and you want something
like my fitness pal managed to to trip
over their own feet at the same time as
a major competitor
why not use chronometer for everything
why have chronometer to do micros and
macro factor for macros
it's just not got the best
um like database of popular brand items
chronometer um and macro fact is not it
macro Factor has micronutrient profiles
but it's not quite as good as
chronometer
um so chronometer is good for like
inserting the single ingredients once
and like doing that process once but if
I'm gonna have like a
dinner a restaurant with the chance of
being chronometer of isolate I tested it
because ideally that would be what you
would do right but yeah the the database
and also the track of the functionality
on macro factors Way Beyond that it'll
even adjust your Macros for you if you
want it to is that the thing when we
went for a avocado salad in Heaton a few
months ago Yusuf that you just spoke it
into your phone he says yeah records one
avocado salad with an egg and then it
just came up and put it in yeah so that
I mean that's a great feature I feel
like we've not even mentioned yeah I
haven't even mentioned that yeah so it's
got like an AI recognition thing so you
could say
um yeah roast chicken dinner with
potatoes aren't whatever and it'll it'll
generate it and it'll give you suggested
servings and you go oh yeah that's about
right and you can add it in
um the we I think we have a code for
that as well but it's just for an
extended trial yeah they don't do any
discounts sadly
um
yeah they do have seven or a 14-day
trial
so good how much is membership if you
want to stick about after that
60 quid a year or something like that
yeah
if you're the basis of your tracking
yeah yeah so if you've used something
like MyFitnessPal or something like that
in the past
um and you want an equivalent and you
also want it to adjust your Macros for
you it also gives you like an estimated
end date for so you plug in like your
target weight
it recommends some calories for you it
tells you how long your diet is going to
be and it adjusts to your Macros each
week based on how what your weight
changes to wow wow so it's pretty cool
um is it Mike Israel has got no it's not
it's uh Zach's friend from uh thingy
strength that has a great name I can't
remember the [ __ ] name of it
maybe uh that has a an AI lifting
program now oh Juggernaut Juggernaut
training system thank you yeah um and
he's basically created a scalable
completely leverageable ultimately
scalable personalized training platform
yeah so I've given that a try
um it's pretty impressive I don't use it
personally but
um I've seen some examples of like some
quite high level power lifters using it
and peeking for it and I think so the
guys the the sort of the developer guy
behind it I think is called
Garrett Levins I think his name is he's
a us uh on the US powerlifting team
who's just like coded an app for
can I just wedge in a post hack for for
Johnny's there which is also if you
struggle if you're not very inventive
with meal planning use eat this much so
either an app or a website eat this
much.com and you just say like I'm
having breakfast or dinner or lunch and
it says oh do you do you like
blueberries do you like almonds whatever
and it's just generate you
things that you should eat as a meal
plan it's very good
um so my hack
is the wobbly sausage
I recently what are you brandishing at
us
this is my wobbly sausage
it's a theraband I believe it's not
going to go in focus is it
um I've been plagued with elbow problems
over the last few months and this has
been the only thing that's helped to fix
it
so if you're someone who does a lot of
things like weighted chin-ups and heavy
rows and stuff that just really
aggravates that bit of your elbow
it's possible because I'm living proof
to get golfer's elbow without having
ever played golf
um and tennis elbow without having ever
played tennis so
and it's so painful and it gets to the
point where like using your handbrake in
your car or opening jars and stuff is
exquisitely painful so
the wobbly sausage is brilliant
just something that you can then do like
negatives with you can do lots of reps
and it it does you get a pump on exactly
the area that is sore so for the people
that are for the people that are
listening are not able to see what it is
that you're brandishing at us you're not
using this as a soft tissue tool you're
using a kind of rolling pin flexible
rolling pin to actually do movements
forward and back with your wrists yeah
using it as twisty or you can use it as
actual like this is genuinely one of the
exercises
yeah let's let's go study with that one
shall we I don't want to get demonetized
and I also don't I don't believe you you
said that's one of the exercises so the
the guide even had like one where you
you get a band and you hold it with your
right hand standing up with your left
foot and then you do that overhead to
try and stabilize your shoulder wow I
mean I'm sure that you understand the
mechanism that's going on why does
golfer's elbow occur what's happening
so it's it's been debated because it
used to be the theory that it was an
inflammatory process and now we think
it's to do with the tendon Matrix
getting disrupted
um but it can just it it's probably like
a combination of tissue level and
sensitization events happening at that
point but it's just so localized and so
painful that anything you do starts
picking the scab with it so part of the
goal is to like stretch it away work
through the pain a little bit get get
you know after you've recovered
to re desensitize yourself to the area
but then also to strengthen the area
through doing lots of negatives and
wobbly sausage yeah well I was going to
ask what the [ __ ] mechanism was if
you were going to say it looks like a
miniature foam roller right looks like a
tiny little foam roller I was gonna say
what are you actually doing if you're
going to go back and then do the same
exercise again how are you expecting a
different result if all you've done is
loosen up the area like this was what I
got red pilled by Sam Spinelli uh the
strength therapist uh about a little
while ago
foreign
we're gonna have to explain that so
we're laughing because Dr Sam Spinelli
uh had a handle on Instagram called the
strength therapist now one of the
problems if you write out the strength
therapist all in one word without
capital letters you can also spell the
strength the rapist and it seems like he
became aware of this after a while and
changed it to at Dr Sam Spinelli anyway
what he told me was that soft tissue
feels nice but doesn't make a massive
amount of difference to long-term injury
unfortunately it it's it's a way to kind
of get temporary access to a new range
of motion or a new kind of pain-free
range that you then have to do something
with you can't just do the foam rolling
and then be like I've done I've done the
work now
what's the brand of that thing again for
people that want to check it out it is
theraband
they're quite a big company they seem
like uh
that seems like an oddly brand name
purchase for you yourself that you would
have probably tried to get from Alibaba
I I just thought I'm not I'm not making
any shortcuts with my elbow I've I've
wrestled with this problem enough yeah
um I got the green greeny blue you know
what you call that turquoise one yeah
um there's different levels this is the
medium I believe and I think it's just
about right for Rehab don't regret that
not getting a stronger one
no because you I think if you go too
hard with it it's you're just kind of
picking the scab further with the injury
it's such a like nuanced topic about
when you look at resistance bands and
and other
um the density of foam rollers do I want
extra firm do I want firm do I want
medium because there's no way there's no
gradient that you can actually test
until you get it and the number of times
that you get it and go for [ __ ] sake
this is way too soft or way too light
I'm gonna have to basically just buy
another one have you ever gone too hard
I think I got the captain of crush and I
got like level four or something
thinking uh and it's like
oh like three people in the world have
ever closed it
or if you like accidentally get a you
know if you're trying to get like a
resistance band to do some shoulder
rehab with and you you get something
that's too much and you can't even get
it past like yeah
but then there's one that's totally
pointless that you can basically see
through is also useless like I'm just
flinging a piece of single sheet of
toilet paper around here yeah yeah
exactly okay
um hack productivity with the zygonic
effect by leaving sentences part
finished we've spoken about the zyganic
effect before it is a psychological bias
that was discovered by this guy who was
studying waiters and waitresses in uh
restaurants and he was very impressed
it's super impressive when you see
someone that comes up and asks you your
order and doesn't write anything down
and just looking at you while you say it
this lady did it in Vegas for an entire
table of 10 people drinks starters and
Mains didn't write a single thing down
nothing was wrong and it all came out to
the right people as well it's like
[ __ ] hell like that's that's that's
20 20 to 25 tip worthy like if you want
to do like to give us a bit of a
flourish you do some card tricks or sing
or something but
um what this guy realized is that the
servers had an unbelievably accurate
ability to recall what each table had
ordered while the orders and checks were
still open and as soon as the checks had
gone their ability to remember things
had completely vanished it's the same as
anyone who like me at University crammed
for exams you'll be able to remember
really really closely what it is all of
the different accounting principles or
whatever that you've been researching
and yet as soon as the exam's done and
that Loop is closed
everything's gone and this is the same
reason that Netflix shows use
Cliffhangers at the end of them to get
you to watch the next one because the
human mind abhors this sort of open loop
and it likes a closed loop so it's the
open and closed loop Dynamic that we've
got and the way that you can use this to
hack productivity is give yourself an
easier in when you go to restart a
project and this is something Michael
malice does as a writer I know a bunch
of my other writer friends do as well
that they leave sentences part finished
as they close the day out which means
that when they then begin the next day
it's really easy how hard is it to
finish the sentence like you already
you're basically up and running already
and then you before you know what you're
writing it also means that your open
loop system is a little bit more
activated throughout the remainder of
the break between doing the project
again finishing it and doing it again so
you're thinking about it a bit more
you're considering what it is that you
need to do so I do that with some of the
stuff that I'm starting to right now I'm
starting to do some longer form stuff
and uh yeah leaving sentences part
finished is a nice solution nice so
you're not having to start the day and
kind of crack the shell of the task and
it's oh [ __ ] finishing something at
the at the end of a chapter you know and
you go okay let's start this new chapter
now really really difficult it's hard
enough to begin a task in any case it's
just a case of making it as easy as
possible for you to get going I think
I think we discussed the idea of
dentists when
you come in the room and they go hello
sir sit down and then you open your
mouth and go ah Lewis how are the kids
like because they recognize the
particular configuration of fillings and
teeth that you've got and that's that's
what jogs their memory because that's
the way that they see the world
that's not one that I remember happening
but yeah I mean I'm going to see David
Bretton actually in a couple of weeks
time before I go back to uh Texas so if
he starts remembering things about me as
soon as I open my mouth
we'll know that that's true Johan
contact specific learning
um
Andrew heberman
who is a alumnus of the modern Muslim
podcast has a sleep cocktail or either
of you tried it magnesium L3 and 8.
Chris has tried yep a pigeon in yeah and
sometimes sometimes not uh Gaba
so the guy the glycine thing I haven't
you I haven't tried yet so I haven't
tried the Gabba because Yousef scared me
about Gaba we we used to gabber a lot
in in z12 yeah back in the day however
I got through a bottle again I gave it
to my brother and he ended up getting
withdrawal I like I gave it to him I was
like listen
Habibi don't take this every day every
couple of days and then of course he
didn't he ignored me took two every day
and then the end of the month he's more
or less I
told you man
I'm [ __ ] telling you bro stop taking
that [ __ ] sorry it's my crew I remember
you said realizing there was Gaba in
their supplement we used to take from T
Nation and being like whoa that's hell
of a that's a sledgehammer so I didn't I
haven't even added that in but the rest
of it I have and my goodness me
do you get a good night's sleep with
that cocktail thing have you split
tested it on whoop
I haven't
I haven't but I mean he's still using
whoop no well that's why you haven't
done it well you'll be back you'll be
back you'll be back maybe through 2023
maybe the thing that's good about whoop
I mean not to Sidetrack this is like is
exactly for stuff like this so it's it's
activating it for I I don't think I get
that much out of it when I do the same
things day in day out because it just
there's a flux in your scores and you're
like well I'm not going to change my
training but if you want to add
something new in like red light therapy
for example
um or new sleep supplements doing it for
like two months and testing it just to
see like is there any move in the
numbers is very useful but with the
Sleep cocktail thing it's almost at the
point where it's like it's as clear as
day to me that it makes a difference
like I I don't know what your experience
with it was Chris but
um I've had a lot of sleep supplements
about zma obviously the z12 stuff
um 5-HTP my proteins sleep cocktails
never it they kind of help that they
don't really um
I think this I immediately fall asleep
and then I just feel like I'm asleep the
entire night no issues my sleep's been
the best that it's been uh throughout
this year and it's fluctuated due to all
of the travel but I'm a big fan I
haven't used the glycine so for Brands
I'll let you put yours forward but
certainly in America and maybe in the UK
as well a company called DoubleTree
they are massive on Amazon
um everything seems to be a double
third-party tested comes with a bunch of
credentials and stuff
um that's where I get my magnesium L3
and 8 from my epigenan and my is that
how I say it I feel like a genuine I
think yeah I'm definitely saying like a
a pigeon and which is I'm pretty sure
Issa if you mentioned that's an opiate
possibly I it's a thing in chamomile tea
oh is it okay but no I don't know if
apogenic is but chamomile tea is a mild
opiate well l-theanine is present in
green tea green tea yeah yeah gives you
some funky dreams yeah well I mean
l-theanine's a really great
neuroprotective seems to be good for
dealing with Stress and Anxiety some
people take it during the morning as
well which is also useful to take with
caffeine to take the Jitters off the
edge of caffeine
um what's the brands that you've gone
for what's the dosage you go for and
where did you get your glycine from
I just got it all on Amazon
um I can get the The Links of stuff
um I got it to be honest I went on
Amazon and I went for brands that I
either recognized or had like really
good reviews and like a high number of
reviews on
um it was a lot cheaper than I was
expecting it to be getting all the
individual ingredients and a lot of like
the theme there's like 180 days in a
bottle or something like that I've still
got that uh epigenin from the first time
I started using it because they're tiny
tiny teeny little capsules right
um the Magnesium L3 and 8 is what you go
through at a ridiculous rate yeah so you
need to get three I've found that you
need to get about three bottles of the
magnesium for every one of the other two
glycine is it is it any type of glycine
I haven't used it it's very generic and
cheap so it's just amino acid yeah the
the reason that they say the cycle it is
that the data shows like an increase in
Sleep Quality on the first night that
you use it and then not so much
afterwards so the the rationale
huberman's rationale will be to cycle it
so that you kind of re-sensitize to it
are you cycling because I don't but
should you be cycling magnesium L3 and 8
uh epigenin and
the health personally with with anything
like that that's going to enhance
something I just think a broad principle
should be to cycle stuff the only time
the only thing anything that I maybe
wouldn't is anything that's vitamin or
pseudo vitamin so creatine no need to
cycle
but things that are like anti-stress
sleep adaptogens anything like that I
would cycle so so magnesium you wouldn't
cycle and if it's a magnesium I wouldn't
yeah wouldn't but a bit and glycine you
wouldn't although I was slightly hyper
magnesemic uh from my last blood test
which shows I was like scooping it in so
what do you use on an evening time Yusuf
because I imagine you don't subscribe to
this kind of
cocktail I've been rotating magnesium
sources just because I know some people
are proper magnesium perverts but um
I've just got some currently magnesium
chloride powder that I or Crystal that I
just unflavored unflavored rice soup
that you what what do you do with it I
just tries I put it into the water or
something but not your mouth to be
honest very irresponsible of me please
don't take this as medical advice
because I like I just haven't been
weighing it out I just sort of eyeball
it which is a terrible thing to do with
a mineral and it's why I ended up Magnus
the eyeball that's like in the studies
where people have like accidentally had
30 grams of caffeine and ended up that
was that person in northumbria
University wasn't it yeah yeah someone
around the world who don't know the the
university were talking about those two
Unis in the city that we all live in and
they did a study on caffeine and
somebody accidentally was it a hundred
times the dose yeah it's meant to be 300
milligrams I believe and then you gave
30 grams which like there's so many
steps that you would realize that that's
wrong that they just managed to somehow
Miss well I think not only the fact that
it's so bitter even if you have 300
milligrams of caffeine powder in a pint
of water you can taste it like it's
really nasty taste it in three liters of
water it's such a strong but then the
three of us would have seen the pile on
the heaped protein scoop of caffeine
gone
I think that's a bit much caffeine
[ __ ] hell okay yeah Andrew human
sleep cocktail I'm completely in I've
used it throughout this year uh if you
just Google that by the way if you just
Google Andrew huberman sleep cocktail
you'll find like all the recommendations
what to cycle once and what not to cycle
all the dosages and that sort of stuff
yeah uh what was it very very good
something else
that
something sleepy oh that was it so Derek
from more plates mod dates his gorilla
mind gorilla mode
um company has done a version of
huberman's sleep cocktail okay but the
one thing they did was put melatonin in
it
I'm like mate come on come on come on
come on son so I think he's going to
redo another version where melatonin
isn't in it the problem is the Americans
are so [ __ ] Pro melatonin it is
insane because you can buy it over the
counter you can get it on Amazon you can
get it wherever you can't get it on
prescription in the UK it's basically
impossible to get on prescription and
yet it's sold over the counter in
America because like whoa drugs and that
just means that people throw they'll
lump it in with every like cake mix
I think it was last life hacks where you
were talking about like getting
something like 500 ibuprofens in a tub
maybe I mean they do those they they
don't do the blister pack thing very
much if you want to kill yourself by
taking drugs in America it's pretty easy
because you just go into CBS and they've
just got a big fat yeah exactly these
protein powder-sized boxes and you're
just twinkling all of these
all the adverts do you wake up in the
morning and go to sleep at night then
maybe you need melatonin maybe you need
20 milligrams of melatonin every day
anyway I got some in Hawaii and used to
like they were like two milligram
gummies yep and when I asked you
recommendation for Davis he was like cut
it into quarters
have one maybe one quarter and then slow
maybe have a second if you need to
what's the what's the 30 second red pill
on melatonin dosage so melatonin the the
best effect from it is from it basically
starting the lead Domino of your natural
endogenous melatonin production so you
shouldn't be trying to like substitute
it's not like
testosterone replacement where you're
you're just like taking the full lot
it's just to get it going
um and that's why it's got this inverted
U curve dose response so there's like a
midpoint where about one milligram seems
to be optimal and then more than that or
less than that is less effective
and they sell 10 milligram 20 milligram
tablets of military for LOLs in CVS
you're [ __ ] just yeah right you
cusaph what have you got
when you are giving a speech or dealing
with a client or dealing with a patient
or anything and you get lost in the
middle of something
the great hack is just to put yourself
in context so if I was drawing a blank
now
so we're currently talking about life
hacks in general we've gone through some
physical ones some digital ones Chris
and Johnny have given their suggestions
and now we're on to mine and often that
alone just
geography memory and gets you going
again so if you're in the middle of a
speech and you're like oh and the
audience appreciate it as well it's not
as if
um it looks bad because the audience
like oh great like we're back in context
again just let's just show everyone
where we are in the map and then here's
where we are going next
I really like that that's brilliant that
saved my ass a lot of times Alex
O'Connor does something kind of similar
it's not I don't it maybe to cover up
when he loses his place but he does uh
he asks a rhetorical question that makes
it obvious about where he's going to go
next so let's say that he was doing some
video about
Jordan Peterson's views on veganism or
something and he would say something
along the lines of so you might ask
yourself why would it be the case given
everything that we know about Jordan's
beliefs around Humanity needing to be as
generous and kind as possible that he
would not have decided to adopt a
plant-based diet well the reason for
that is
and like all of that what he's done is
he's created a question that he can
answer himself he's opened a loop you
want him to answer it like it's a he's
like interviewing himself
um I very much and he does that when
he's doing his YouTube videos he'll go
off script to do that to then go back on
script and it's you can do it with all
of the naturalistic language that you
need you can do all the rest of it it's
a really really and Zach started putting
that same tactic into his videos on
YouTube too it's like so you might think
like why would someone do this well the
reason that you could say perhaps they
might do this is and then you're back on
script so you've just veered off and
come back on but it's so it's just easy
to inject you do that one or two times
per talk
no one's going to notice but it's a
really good tactic
nice I love that good one okay
um
I guess given the fact that Johnny's
just spoken about the uh sleep stuff I
might as well throw this in so I did 500
days without caffeine
um I then reintroduced caffeine back
into my use but wanted to maintain the
current level of sensitivity that I have
to caffeine and most importantly not
reintroduce the dependence that I had to
caffeine Alex homozy has this [ __ ]
amazing quote when it comes to Reliance
on substances caffeine in particular
that says if you can't perform without
it it stopped conferring a benefit and
you're like look that is the way that
most people view caffeine they don't use
it to improve performance they use it to
get themselves back to zero and it's no
longer assisting you it's no longer
performance enhancer it's just
buttressing what you do with your life
so for me the best way to do it is just
every other day caffeine use and the the
reason that it works as a rule is I can
always remember if I had caffeine
yesterday and if I did I can't have it
today
that's it it also means if I'm thinking
about having caffeine today I actually
have to make a scarcity calculation
about how much do I need it today and
how much might I need it tomorrow if I
need it in two days time it doesn't
really matter but if I'm going to need
it tomorrow more than I'll need it today
I won't take it now I do exactly that
I'm like planning two three days ahead
of like oh no if I have one today the
last two days in a row so I can't do it
no I'm not a hot number
you can borrow from tomorrow then so if
I'm not just supposed to have any today
I'm supposed to have some tomorrow but I
need it tomorrow today more than
tomorrow can I borrow from tomorrow not
if you've had it yesterday
can't ever have it two days in a row you
could go more than two days without
caffeine for example so yeah if you can
go more than two days without but you
can't go more than two days in a row
with I see and that's actually create
like a really complicated credit system
with a spreadsheet of like okay I'm this
many in reserve and yeah yeah I've
ranked I've banked this many days no but
this is the reason that it's super easy
because you can't do two in a row but
you can do two without in a row and
that's it you just hold on to that and
it's meant that I'm still taking so kill
Cliff uh it looks like we might be doing
some work with them next year a massive
fan of what they do
um natural Preserve no preservatives no
additives no nothing else flash
pasteurized blah blah blah loads of
l-theanine uh they do a 25 milligram uh
drink
which is basically just I mean it's half
a half a cup of coffee and it's just
about enough to give you a little push
especially if you're sensitive with it
like I am at the moment uh for
non-physical activities 25 migs is about
right for me uh to go down and do some
mental work and then if I want to train
they do a a 90 and a 125 in Jocko uh go
also is a 90 migs
perfect like and that I feel the hell
out of that like seeing people walk
around with a bang energy that's 350
milligrams of caffeine just blows my
mind Zach will go and get a rain energy
300 milligrams of caffeine before we go
on train and I can like I I get
caffeinated by watching him drink it so
yeah every other day caffeine use really
really good
so you must be pretty damn sensitive to
it then yeah crazy sensitive I mean if
you if you had like three or four
coffees in a day does that how do you
feel the sensitivity is it in just like
Jitter I've since I've come back on I've
never had I think the most I've ever had
in a day has been two 25 milligram
drinks but if you scoot back to like pre
500 day with episode I can't remember
because my sensitivity was just so high
right that's so low should I say I was
so desensitized to the effect of
caffeine I can't remember what it was
like but it would make me if I overshoot
it it makes me jittery it makes me
anxious I can't focus
um and I don't need it like my energy
levels are not determined by the
caffeine concentration in my blood
anymore and this is the this is the big
thing about caffeine that it's papering
over the cracks in the issues that your
daily routine has created like people
are using caffeine to get themselves
past the 11AM slump but never having to
ask them ourselves why the [ __ ] am I
tired at 11AM dude you're not supposed
to be tired and fatigued and needing
your adenosine system to be completely
hijacked by a massive energy drink at 11
30 a.m maybe it's because you're not
sleeping enough maybe it's because
you're not getting enough daylight maybe
it's because you're not spending enough
time outside whatever
it's it's pathological
um I'm gonna I'm gonna Bank a couple of
caffeine related hacks for after
Johnny's all right okay Johan okay cool
um
mine's more just like a behavioral thing
so
um
I have found I'm I think probably every
struggles with this like you have a long
list of boring things to do
you've got like something in the like to
tidy the house or something like that or
do some admin
um
even just if you if you're putting off a
training session
um it's something that
that I've always kind of done it in some
way but the first time I really
experienced the effect of just having a
like a totally arbitrary deadline was
actually when I was trying to do the
cross for open when you were there Chris
and you were just like
five four three and I just found myself
even though I was
shattered I think you're just like oh
well there's the countdown I suppose I
better get back to doing what I was
doing so you having just this arbitrary
thing that just encourages you to just
get going again so being like playing
around with that to encourage me to do
things that I'm putting off so
um you've got like a list of boring
tasks that you've got to do and you've
got a phone call that's happening at one
o'clock challenge yourself to do as many
many of them as you can before one
o'clock or even sometimes waiting until
you've only got an hour to train like
you know your training session's gonna
take you an hour I know that at 11 30
I'm gonna have one hour exactly to train
otherwise I'll miss my training session
suddenly you find yourself like in the
gym powering through it getting it done
in 45 minutes so kind of creating these
like almost turning things into a bit of
a game it's a bit childish but it makes
such a difference to things that are
otherwise very boring and could easily
have taken all day
um and I know it's it's Parkinson's laws
and lots of other ways of kind of
viewing these things but when you've got
stuff you don't want to do turn it into
a bit of a game set a random and
arbitrary deadline and suddenly becomes
like even fun
there's something I really admire about
you Johnny and you this is parallel to
Parkinson's law is you know the effect
of when like you're at home and you've
got a train to catch a quarter past four
so but it's it's quarter past three and
so you're thinking well I've got an hour
but I can't really do anything proper
and then there's like half an hour
before you have to leave and you're like
well like I'm in this limbo Johnny will
always just be like I'll just do a thing
like so something you know even if you
have to record a module or something
that I would consider quite heavy
Project work and you'll be like that's
fine like I just need to leave at that
time and I'll just do it anyway whereas
I get very much caught in limbo mode and
end up doing like emails or shallow work
well that was a cancer that was
something that you that I still use from
you which is having a holding pattern
activity so in between I've had a lot of
calls over the last few months and
sitting down and waiting and call
finishes 10 minutes before your next
call really what are you going to do not
even long enough for me to do a loop of
the park next to where I live that's 13
minutes and 30 seconds door to door so
I'm like right well iPad or a Kindle
next to my desk means that instead of
picking up my phone I might pick up a
book maybe I'll read for a little bit or
emails I think is actually the best use
of your time for this because you can
chip away your emails in such an easy
bite size form I'm going to try it
email's been a real issue for me so if
anyone has some great life hacks around
emails please send them over
um to try and make email less of a an
entire day thing currently 120 unread
emails all of which need in-depth
replies that need me to get a calendar
out or link other stuff or submit a form
or do some [ __ ] uh
how are you gamifying common boring
tasks like just saying I've got half an
hour to do these I need to get these
done is there anything else so uh it
depends what it is but I'll always try
and pair it with something that's
um
fun or enjoyable so like
emails that require a long complex reply
it's a little bit different but I'll
have a 30 minute battery I'm like I've
got 30 minutes I'm going to call it X
I've got like a predefined list of all
these things and I know that like really
bitty like
renew my car tax pay this thing reset
this insurance whatever it is I'll stick
a whatever I'm listening to podcast
course whatever on in the background set
a timer for 30 minutes and just try and
get all of them done in the time and it
turns it into this like
you've got to do it anyway you've got to
do those things at some point anyway you
either do the money you don't do them so
you're going to do them you might as
well try and compress it and make it
take the least of your day possible turn
it into a bit of a challenge and pair it
with something that like takes the edge
off so like a listen to a podcast or
even just your favorite album or
whatever
um
but yeah I think
forcing yourself to it's something I
actually I think it was like a Tim
Ferriss tip from years ago which was
like create positive constraints in your
day so CR like make plans at 4pm that
force you to finish work by 4 pm or set
like set things that happen throughout
your day that are fixed that mean that
suddenly you've not got all morning to
do something you've got 90 minutes to do
something and you'll still do it and it
turns into a bit of a challenge or
you're still you still always fit your
training in multiple times a week even
if you're really busy you just kind of
find the time and make it make it take a
little bit less time in the gym
big amorphous [ __ ] work blob just
allows everything to bleed into
everything else yeah you need structure
you really do I like I like that a lot
that's good I think um
uh calling people while you're doing
like house tasks is another really good
one or listening obviously listening to
a podcast if you don't have anybody to
call or if you can't be bothered if
you've got a full clothes or sort [ __ ]
out or whatever you're off to print some
stuff and return some parcels like just
ring someone and it's gonna make it a
little bit less [ __ ] and you've got to
do it in any case
definitely Yusuf
so we're winding back to caffeine if
you've been convinced by Chris's
argument there to to just stop relying
on caffeine if you're one of these
people who you're like oh actually my
energy levels are dictated by my serum
caffeine levels or
um I I can't function without it
the first thing you can try from
probably about six life hacks ago is
Johnny's decaffeination protocol so
that's let's say you have three cup
three coffees a day
9 A.M 12 p.m and 3 P.M you do three
weeks where you substitute the last
coffee so the 3pm one for decaf
and then the next week you go the midday
and the 3 P.M on a decaf and then you go
then the 9 A.M the 12 a.m and the the 9
12 and 3 are all decaf and then you
reintroduce them slowly over time so
then you've you've managed to wean
yourself off without having to go
through all the caffeine headaches and
withdrawals and then you you're getting
the most out of the least when you
reintroduce it so that's a good way to
do it if you need something with a
little bit more fine tuning
then I've got two options for you one of
them is
called norlow lightly caffeinated coffee
so this is some kind of Scandinavian
coffee brand that is like a third of the
caffeine of normal coffee
so it doesn't have that decaf taste and
it's
it it's pretty good it's very it's all
like minimal design and really kind of
cool looking lightly caffeinated coffee
so you could go for that and then you
can play around with your protocol and
maybe have that at midday as your final
one or something
the other option that I've been having
recently if you're a tea fan is hojicha
so you might have heard of matcha which
is the the powdered green tea that's
kind of an acquired taste your juice is
his Arabic cousin
exactly it's an Arab Uncle
lightly roasted
it is actually roasted so it's brown and
it's got more of a
um caramelly malty kind of taste to it
and it's beautiful I think it's really
really nice and you can make cakes with
it there's there's a there's place
there's a place all over the UK called
sujiri which does
hojicha and matcha like soft serve ice
cream or cheesecakes and all that kind
of stuff increasingly Lebanese here yeah
so you can get the hadita powder it's
like 10 pound for a big bag how do you
spell that h-o-u-j-i-c-h-a
and you can make frozen yogurt with it
it's genuinely lovely so you would have
frozen yogurt that's lightly caffeinated
yeah but the hoodicha is actually
because it's roasted it's got lower
caffeine than matcha
but it still has the theanine and all
that stuff too so it's a really nice
kind of almost green tea light but it's
got a kind of multi wholesome flavor to
it
very nice I like it okay let's get
ourselves out of health and fitness and
get into why you should install a USB
charger in your bathroom so it's the
first bathroom what a sentence look we
need to divert
um the first bathroom that I've ever had
a USB charger in is the place that I'm
at in Texas at the moment and it's
fantastic it means that my whoop
external battery is always in the same
place for if I'm taking it off I'm
getting in the shower that's the time
when I'm taking my wearables off in any
case for uh razors electric shavers if
they've got USB compatibility for
um electric toothbrushes all of which
pretty much use USB to power them if
you've got a Sonicare or something
similar
um
what are you doing Yusuf I'm just
prepping for the next steam can you can
you cut yeah can you cut back early
enough so that we can see what he's
doing please fix me up a Mr Bean episode
it was yeah okay so
um yeah it's just you need a USB charger
in your bathroom so if you're doing a
bathroom uh revamp I'm also going to
guess that the same way that the double
prong shaver thing 30 years ago was
sufficiently safe in terms of wattage a
rampage or voltage to be able to be in a
room that might have some Mist I'm going
to guess 100 that a USB
Port is going to be sufficiently safe uh
check with your appropriate electrical
local local Council Electrical Company
before doing this however I've got it in
Texas I haven't killed myself and all of
my devices are very well charged it is
the it's the frustration isn't it with
having so many little devices that
require like a micro or a mini or just a
normal USB that you have to charge them
at kind of different intervals
throughout the week so having like a
slot where you regularly so is that why
you're showering or something like that
that you yes so especially with uh
especially with the whoop I'll just take
it off before I get in the shower
because I don't the strap to get wet
well I might as well plug it in to the
external charger which lives right next
to the little Port so it's always in the
same place it's just an extra Hub
because there isn't for me the kitchen
is where my phone stays and all of the
phone charging stuff tends to live
around there the office would be where
all of my tech for work would be I don't
actually have a very good location for
the wearables in my life I don't want
them next to my bed I think that that's
just too messy
um so where is it that you would go and
it seems to make
I know pretty good sense to me to have
it in the bathroom and the wearables are
going to take them off the same stuff
for shaving same stuff for
cleaning your mouth Etc
yeah I think having like a it's having
the the
the time to charge them when you don't
need them that happens regularly and I
think showering is the as long as
something can charge as a sufficient
amount while you're showering well the
way that I do it or you could do it with
um your whoop for instance or an Apple
watch or something similar could be take
it off to shower first thing in the
morning
go downstairs do whatever you need to do
go back up to clean your teeth
presumably which you're going to do
before you leave
grab it off the shelf that's half an
hour charge during a period you're not
going to get much low intensity steady
state cardio in during that one half
hour but yeah I I think it's a
definitely a good consideration
cool Johan give me something I want to
send this back into health and fitness
can I do that sure
uh one of them's a exercise
technique hack and the other one is an
equipment hack you might not have a bit
of equipment in your gym but if you do
and you've always looked at it I thought
I wonder what that does a safety squat
bar
give a tried one Chris you ever tried
one so that's where you've got handles
on the front and usually a padded sort
of H Shape Up and above you and then
this goes out to the side and then it
kind of yolks down as well right on the
outside of that yeah so the the plates
are like a on a a portion of the bars at
an angle typically the same angle as the
handles so they're kind of tilted
forward a little bit it's a similar
stimulus to a front squat
without the kind of positional issues or
having to get into the front rack or
pinching an artery or something nasty so
it allows you to kind of push the the
lift more without the technical demands
if you're not looking to be an Olympic
weightlifter or whatever
um so the reason I've done it is it's
allowed me to basically like reset a
lift so the problem I was having with
squatting was doing anything that wasn't
like powerlifting training it's kind of
I'm kind of too
technically too advanced in the lift for
it to kind of be a something I can train
regularly and I just feel it in like
hips and hamstrings and lower back and
kept getting injured with it safety
squat but the loads are way lower
um the training effects really high like
my quads are in pieces for days so if
you've never tried one you don't
particularly like back squatting you
don't particularly like run squatting
there's one in your gym or you've got a
home gym you want to buy one buy one
they're fairly inexpensive
highly highly recommend that
the second thing is if you do lateral
raises
and you find yourself like sometimes you
use like the swing you swing your body
around sometimes they kind of go halfway
sometimes ago to I don't know random
stages
allow as much body swing as much body
English as you want but the range of
motion has to finish completely over
your head with the dumbbells touching
over your head until you're doing stuff
like Star jumps
I think if you try like try
experimenting with an amount of body
English and you'll find it kind of
pleases itself because doing star jumps
actually makes it harder because we I
feel like we've all converged at trying
to get the most out of the least weight
recently with with training so I I've
gone the opposite way with lateral
raises where I do like chest supported
ones so you said okay almost vertical
Lean Forward onto it and honestly doing
like five kilo dumbbells it's
embarrassing but it's a lot harder I
really want to be a part of the movement
but I can't pretend like I haven't just
been throwing stupid heavy weight around
for those times as I just it's been
idiocy 2008 lifting with Z if you're
living with Zach yeah I mean he's 200 60
pounds and six foot four so I've got to
try and catch up with him and his weight
and his strength but yeah uh I
definitely see the advantage of
um increasing the like mechanical
difficulty of a movement in order to
stop yourself from being too stupid with
it that makes a ton of sense
well it's just like the so Mike Israel
talks about it this stimulus fatigue
ratio so like depends why you're
training but if you're training to for
health as you mentioned or like for
muscle gain
it does kind of make sense to get the
stimulus you need
while accumulating the least fatigue
possible like without working yeah
Danger's a big one so like if to train
your legs you have to load up a leg
press or you're deciding to load up a
leg press with as many plates are
available in the gym and doing quarter
range Motion versus like a fifth of that
or a tenth of that and doing full range
motion you're probably less likely to
get injured
though because presumably you could
overshoot it on lightness
you could you definitely could but as
long as you're like progressing your
training you'll eventually find the
point where you're no longer doing that
but if you maintain the range of motion
you shouldn't Theory get a better
training effect is this your going to be
one of your guiding principles as we all
transition into sort of
older man Fitness
yeah within the next 10 years we're all
going to have to genuinely consider
what am I getting out of this session
what are the risks associated with this
session
I think I've just come from my training
historically has been like it just
carried a a consistent risk of I'm
likely to injure myself in this training
cycle like over the next six to eight
weeks and also I would train and then
feel like I've been hit by a bus for one
to two days afterwards so I don't think
it's even I'm likely to I think just
every training cycle is like a quad tear
or something Twins or something yeah
it's always something each cycle so the
fatigue either from a injury perspective
or just the way that training makes you
feel has always been very high for me so
I am now looking to just training she's
taking a different role in my life so
it's like I want to train a couple of
days a week but I don't really want to
feel like I've been run over for a day
after my session and but I still want it
to kind of work so whereas you know
where do you arrive at when combine all
those things so unreasonable Johnny I
know you don't want to feel like you've
been run over twice a week I'm being
selfish aren't I but yeah those are my
goals with it so I think it's a there's
always a time to
sling heavy tin isn't there yes
yeah exactly uh and then it's going to
be more high intensity stuff can be
interesting to start doing classes and
stuff again
throughout 2023 because that was the
best gains and progress that I ever saw
in terms of physique was actually doing
something that wasn't focused on
physique but that was one of your hacks
wasn't it like to do a class because you
just absolutely you you the rising tide
makes you do the cardio that you
wouldn't otherwise have done as far as I
can see the mediator for most people's
outcomes in training is the level of
intensity that they train with most
people aren't that they've got
weights which are not being moved
appropriately which are too light being
done in reps that aren't sufficiently uh
big enough and with rest periods that
are too long just all of that getting
compressed down now that's not to say
that you're supposed to lift too heavy
for too long with too many sets and no
rest but having that externalized to a
class and having that motivation put out
there makes it just made such a huge
difference and my my physiology really
responded to that intensity well this is
going to sound really judgmental though
but it I think it goes even beyond the
technical definition of intensity and
just you go into any gym and people just
usually aren't trying very hard like and
it usually correlates very tightly with
the physique like the results that
they're displaying
do you mean a CrossFit class when you
say class
no it'll be similar it'll be
uh non-technical
strength based class right programming
like CrossFit without the ollie lifting
and some of the technical gymnastics
I think the all that would be needed the
only tweaker will be needed for CrossFit
class is to just I would just be there
the whole time is some kind of like
even if it was like a fortnight of
programming that then repeated a few
times so you could just see that you
were improving in something that would
be it constantly varied is the issue
which sadly is the first part of the
definition first of it it can still be
constantly varied just slightly less
often
just intermittently varied yeah varied
sometimes sometimes varied whenever
regularly periodized functional
movements performed at high intensity
yeah man I mean I I've been saying for
ages I can't believe Barry's boot camp
and there's this thing called Orange
Theory In America which you might not be
familiar with
um spin classes Soul cycle all this [ __ ]
no one has done here is a
bro split
three days a week training plan
done it what you would do on your own
plus 30 intensity programmed out and
then finished up with like a nice easy
little mechan of push-ups and pull-ups
or escorts and running or some [ __ ] like
I would
be I would fist [ __ ] that it would be so
perfect and yet every you're trying to
kind of even with on it on its
programming is good but I'm still trying
to like reverse engineer what it is that
I want I don't want to do [ __ ] four
rounds of wall balls I don't care about
the training stimulus of four rounds of
wall balls
um but you know we're getting there
slowly over time I know what you mean
I'd be on it with you if that existed
especially if it was like how CrossFit
is where you log on to like get the work
out the day or whatever
um
should be done anyway yourself there you
go
my girlfriend really upsets me when I
see her trying to open an app because
she'll scroll to like the fourth page
and look for it and like just use
spotlights just use the like scroll down
and type the name of the thing
but one step even further is that you
can access spotlight
from the home screen
from the lock screen
[Music]
so
I think so
so you can just I've just done it now oh
there we go
just scroll down but what happens if you
try and open an app without I'm gonna
guess it's gonna say in order to open
this you then need to put your face ID
in yeah but if you have face ID enabled
by the time it's opened it's probably
recognized your face and
so you've saved for a few seconds I've
just done it Chris and it does just open
so I suppose it's it's face ID and you
while you're yes
yeah access Spotlight from the home
screen by swiping down that's lovely
very nice look that is lovely
um what have I got here so I've got
two hacks I've got a lot of travel hacks
that I'm Gonna Save for another one a
little bit later in the year when people
are probably going to be traveling more
however I'm gonna do two for London
Heathrow because I've used these a lot
throughout this year the first one is
that there is a second Preta monje at
gate A3 in Heathrow Terminal Five and
the main pretamonte which is right in
the the larger Atrium is is way too busy
it is nice they do have a good selection
of of foods and coffees but no more than
a smaller Pratt would have however the
second pretamonte is at gate A3 so you
go past underneath the the walkway you
go past the wh Smith you take a left and
it's there on your left that's very very
good the other thing that you can do
that's a photo Johnny of you at the
pretormanje sending it to me after I
featured it in a newsletter yes indeed
something that might be quite noticeable
about that is there is no queue outside
zero Q it's a secret Preta mange if you
want access to a secret pretormanji
you're in the right place uh second one
sneak into the business Lounge at
business Lounge South at Heathrow
Terminal 5. so in many business lounges
you need to scan your boarding pass in
order to be able to get in the business
Lounge South at Heathrow Terminal 5 is
you just show your boarding pass and
they then scan it in they're always all
of the girls behind the desk who are
perfectly lovely are always talking
they're chit chatting between themselves
easy to sneak in I went back and forth
from it without having been checked once
and I had access to the business Lounge
but they didn't check and if you're in
there the world is your oyster quicker
Wi-Fi great smoothies uh free bar free
food lovely seating it's a very selfless
hack because you pay for that so you're
creating a free rider problem even
though I have to eat yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah of course I'll be in the other
Lounge where this can the passes
properly
oh peasants
is it not that they just can't believe
it's Chris from Modern wisdom and they
just let you in even though look at how
you've changed from Chris from love
island or Chris from Voodoo events you
just need to continue to update the the
bio Chris Carnage [ __ ] house digging
into the archive there uh oh yeah so
second pratamanjo gate A3 and sneak into
the business Lounge in Heathrow Terminal
5. business Lounge is very very nice by
the way should we do one more round
let's get one more round in come on
Johnny let's do it uh this is a music
recommendation
so if anybody
is or used to be a fan of like rage
against machine or Audio Slave uh Chris
Cornell any of that sort of stuff
um and to be honest any any rocker from
that genre of music there's a group
called brass against
on YouTube which is like a brass band
with a rotation of singers
and they cover quite a lot of rage
against Machine music and it is honestly
phenomenal
I showed it to a few people and they've
messaged me back saying like I've just
been down a brass against rabbit hole
they have this this the singer she is
I mean it sounds like Zach de la Rocha
the original singer from raise against
machine but like good gym music just
good good General
music really really good brass against
are they I'm gonna guess they'll be on
Spotify as well I'm not sure where they
are I'm not actually checked
um but all the stuff that I've listened
to has been on on YouTube so you must be
YouTube premiuming this
I I am YouTube premiuming this opening
it closing it right I see yeah I I mean
they're on they are on Spotify of all of
the life hacks that we're going to talk
about today they're being a brass band
equivalent of Rise Against I did not
have on my rage against machine whatever
so there's also Richard Cheese who does
Lounge versions of like System of a Down
and Nirvana
wake up grab yourself a little makeup
it's great it's very it seems to be a
winning formula
all right you Steph what you got
so
I feel like I'm cringing a little bit
about this one oh
but I really like these
so these are Alex homozy branded nasal
strips the nasal strips yeah the reason
I'm cringing is because since Alex
hormuzy has popularized them everyone
and their uncle has started doing videos
on Instagram while wearing them as some
kind of like
a status symbol I don't know like it's
because come on like you're recording a
video with good lighting and good camera
and stuff and you didn't you neglected
to take off your stupid nose strips
you're clearly doing it to try and
Signal something but that set aside the
use of I want you to sell me on wearing
another strip yeah sorry
about your own hack
[Laughter]
so
you have a nose like me you might think
surely the the size of those colossal
nostrils doesn't need more assistance
[ __ ] cavernous
for ventilation opening opening them up
requires you to put a land registry down
so that you can walk through
permission
but what they do before bed is and I've
got to avoid my piercing here otherwise
I end up so you put it just over the
kind of nasal Bridge
and it does just enhance your
listen to that clear passage does it
does it do that because it's it's got
something on it or in it like yeah the
it's obviously sort of plaster material
but inside it has a backbone a flexible
spine that pulls your nostrils apart so
if you're a bit of a snorer if you're
finding
that you just want to improve your nasal
breathing or encourage it this is a
better alternative than for example
people doing math tape which you know if
you do get blocked nose that could be a
bit unsafe so instead rather than
blocking off the opposite it's
encouraging the thing you're trying to
do now did you go for Breathe Right
media oh my God if you go for Breathe
Right large
I've gone for
Harmony life oh okay is that from
presumably from Alibaba it sounds like a
life insurance company did you have to
get one for Arab size noses
yeah you've got to go like you have to
take your ethnicity as you uh as you
select the order icon time if you're
joking are you joking I mean how racist
would that be I mean it's
it's
it's
sometimes the sort of thing you have to
fill in though isn't it granted rarely
when you're just ordering something
online you kind of caught off guard why
do you need that information so I back
to your comment Chris I didn't think on
this episode of life hacks I would be
the only one here
without a pack of nasal strips to hand
well I've got two here actually I feel
like and I both breathe right um but I
went for two different sizes see that's
the large are the breathe right ones I
love how it's large and original [ __ ]
Focus you [ __ ] it's not gonna what if I
hide behind yeah it's focused
75 of adult noses I want to see the 25
lifts open nasal passages for up to 31
more airflow Breathe Right nasal strips
may help reduce or even eliminate
snoring
uh are yours oh Naturals or are they
mentholated no they're
Yusuf won't have gone for the Menthol
because of estrogen hahaha
this actually does surprisingly the
large ones do kind of smell Tony a bit
mentally but I don't think that they are
I don't think they're supposed to be
maybe
uh I I just didn't I'll go for it next
time okay I'm not too concerned about
estrogen from menthol
thank goodness
I think the Menthol sounds like it would
be the best bit
maybe it could be the kind of it's above
your nose how are you gonna have Menthol
I don't know she'll be able to smell it
won't you yeah maybe let's I'll get mine
on Johnny can you not find something to
put on your nose and then we can all
work yeah sadly
be a bit of Post-it note
good face Chris that's the that's the
makeup face there it is
like that brilliant oh that's lovely
well technically this is a this is on my
nose and it
similar isn't it it's a festive a
festive nasal decongestant that you've
got under do they light up no no Johnny
had a pair of sunglasses briefly okay so
my last one what am I gonna do for my
last one
uh
I'm about to get some nasal strips I
hope we're doing a what are we watching
round
oh yeah of course of course you think
I'm gonna miss off that
because you've just watched it the third
film ever ready for
um okay so how about
this is a final one for traveling but
it's also for people that are staying in
uh hotels since kovid have stopped
turning down people's rooms
they don't they don't do room turn down
service unless you request it and they
say that it's due to covid's safety
regulations how long are they going to
milk that for absolutely not it's
exclusively due to the fact that they
don't want to have to send the maids
around to every different room so when
you check in that is the time every
single time to say can I just make sure
that we're going to have turn down
service every day that I'm here because
if you try and ring them even when you
check in once you've gone up to the room
and you ring down what they'll say is
sorry we need 24 hours notice in order
to be able to plan this in some places
they'll say they'll say that they need
24 hours notice if you do it when you
check in and they say we need 24 hours
notice you go look I've just checked in
that's a ridiculous rule hotels are such
gas lighters they do it with the um
towels and the and washing don't they
they say oh to protect the environment
we're not going to do any laundry unless
you put it in the bath or unless you
request it or something you're like
it's not for the environment that really
you damage the planet and in your
selfish manner yeah you'll use the same
Talent I'm paying 250 quid a night for
this room let me clean my towels yeah I
realize there's a carbon offset here so
yeah ask for a room turned down at a
hotel as soon as you check in it's just
it happened in Guatemala I needed to do
that went three days without a turn down
service and then realized that I needed
to request it which was 24 hours so it's
four days before I actually had my room
turned down uh yeah highly done okay as
is tradition
let's do a little loop around of what
we've been watching Netflix series
documentaries YouTube stuff anyways I'm
so excited isn't he bursting let's see
it
uh should I go first is nasal strips
vibrating with excitement is the the
potatoes now
I'd say a little bit cooler than room
temperature but I'm happy today take it
away Johan
um first one's just come out actually
has anyone seen the first Knives Out
film
is that yes with that new things with
Daniel Craig right yeah no I just no
okay so it's a bit of an acquired taste
but if you've if you enjoy Knives Out
the first film there's a new one called
Glass Onion I think it's called the
neither Knives Out production or
something it's like number one in the UK
on Netflix
um it's pretty good I just really like
Benoit Blanc how does it compare to
Knives Out
uh it's similar
uh hold on what do you mean like so it's
not a sequel is it no it's not a uh no
it's not a sequence
um Benoit blanks in it so he's the okay
the common theme
um
um if you were to raise knives out of
ten would it be higher or lower
it would be this is because you're
deciding whether to watch it or not yeah
is that because you didn't enjoy knives
out so it was just on the threshold so
if it's lower oh wow it probably is
slightly lower
that's a shame the first one was the
first one good
it it's like I say it's just so it's a
really a quiet taste I can either watch
it and think what the [ __ ] is this why
has Johnny recommended this or you'll
find it really funny
I find Benoit Blanc funny Daniel Craig's
character so
what's the one film you've watched over
the last 100 episodes so it was a series
called Devil's hour
and I recommended Johnny to watch it and
he I think it's probably the first thing
that I've ever recommended Johnny to
watch
um that you've not already seen but
so I think it's the best series I've
ever seen wow it's top three for me for
sure I think it goes Breaking Bad
Midnight Mass
Devil's hour the [ __ ] Midnight Mass
it's based on a Stephen King book so
it's really well written and it's
incredible what's Devil's hour
it's got Malcolm Tucker in it right but
it hasn't it's got Malcolm Peter Capaldi
yeah
and now I've got to be very we've got to
tread very carefully here but it's a
psychological Thriller
that is very dark and
has lots of unfolding
unusual events and I think that's all I
can say
okay uh what's it on Netflix
Amazon Prime I think
and how many episodes how long
it's like five or six so it's it's nice
and contained it's not it doesn't feel
like it drags out there are some Series
where you're like oh come on this could
have been like
four episodes rather than 15.
I would say just a editor's note that
when you sort of recommended to me that
my first thoughts were like this is
decently complicated like for something
to just sit back and enjoy there's a lot
of different plot lines and it does take
a couple of episodes to for you to be
like okay this is pretty good and then
the final couple of episodes like the
final one especially where everything's
revealed insane so it's really worth
assisting how how scary is it because
when I hear Thriller suspense I think
scary and I don't I don't do it I love
that you don't like scary I don't I
really don't like scary film
not good with scary films it's not scary
at all
good the devil's hour that that will all
be revealed why it's called that sounds
like it might be scary okay have you
seen treason
no watch just
Netflix came out I may have only come
out yesterday
um I have been recovering with this flu
that has nailed me twice in two
different countries now uh and in the
space of the two days it's been out I've
finished it so I recovered to treason
very good
uh the head of MI6 gets poisoned within
the first three minutes of the series
and then a new understudy takes his
place and it's all political backbiting
and stuff goes on and his family gets
involved and the next lover comes over
and the Russians are in it and
everything and it's just a bunch of
pretty well-known British actors that
you'll be familiar with the Irish mob
boss from that mob series that we were
watching a little while ago isn't it the
one that took uh Ayahuasca on that like
real high class retreat with his wife
and went crazy
um he's in a bunch of people that you'll
recognize from things like the thick of
it just good class of British characters
um yeah easy easy watching five episodes
could
have been a little bit more compelling
but pretty pretty enjoyable pretty
enjoyable watch pretty easy going
nice
um
uh the new the lip vinyanko series
anyone seen that I think it's um
it's on like ITV Player or BBC
um and it just documents the Alexander
lippanyenko I think that's how you
pronounce it
um
like the actual events who was that what
is he uh he was a former Russian KGB
agent guy
I think just him okay just him yeah
there was there was another incident
where like two people got poisoned in
Salisbury I think it was yes uh yeah so
this was this is predates that
um he was like poisoned in a hotel with
um
I don't know and one of the one like
it's it's the most dangerous substance
yeah
um
documents like uh the British police
dealing with it and
um pretty good nice good good series
I think so yeah I I didn't know like
half the stuff that happened and how
like
it's just audacious to just
come into the UK and poison someone with
something like that and then leave again
like this wasn't the guys what were you
guys doing like the cathedral
the the brothers that and went into like
Durham Cathedral or something and no no
I think so no it was in a hotel in
London they put like a nerve agent in a
is it polonium or something like that
um put it in his green tea in a pot of
green tea in a hotel and they then
subsequently found like traces of it in
the green tea that had been like through
days and days of Cycles they still found
traces of it and they had to to bury him
in like a uh metal coffin to this nerve
agent shit's No Joke Man the the as they
were tracking the father and daughter I
think that got popped with it or the the
one in Salisbury they were able to see
where they'd been for hours afterward I
touched this cup oh he'd he'd stood on
this step he'd brushed past this
particular tree or something it's the
the point they're making the in both
dramas about both of those happening is
that like it can there can be a speck of
it on a on a table and you could test
just to the left of it just to the right
of it Miss it entirely
then you have to test exactly where it
is otherwise you can't detect it but if
someone touches it that's it game over
the game over so it's so hard to once it
once has been some of it in somewhere
it's so hard to find it and detect it
and remove it
[ __ ] and it's incredibly toxic okay have
you watched anything else yeah so a
couple of hard tips again to Johnny
because you recommend I think you
recommended both of these the night
manager yeah which was good
had a sort of young Daniel Craig in it
yeah
um it's very charming and very British
I'm talking about the guy that plays
Loki
Tom
thanks
no Tom Hanks that's it Tom Hanks yeah
you're right uh yeah okay that guy I
watched that as well I thought that was
great it's also got here Tom Hiddleston
yeah Tom Hiddleston and he will heal
area both of them are in it okay and Tom
Holland is also in it
um and then the other one was the
suspect
which was also a good kind of
psychological Thriller
with an Irish man
so funnily enough that was actually the
thing I was going to say next so thank
you oh no I've stolen it from you well
no I think I might have said it on the
last life hacks what was the second one
watch the night manager and what's the
other one suspect watch the suspect okay
so that those were my hat tips just and
in terms yeah so just in terms of things
to things right things to to watch Chris
you recommended coffee Zillow a while
back I've seen some of his recent stuff
and he is
a specimen sort of very [ __ ] on the
internet at the moment yeah yeah he's
for for people who haven't heard of him
he's an investigative journalist that
wears signature suspenders and he just
goes after scammers and crypto
Warlords and all these kind of people
and just goes to town and like peels
through the blockchain and looks at the
individual transactions and goes to the
nth degree to just nail people
and he recently nailed some backman
freed from
um s what was the FTX
have you watched the Logan Paul
three-parter
I watched the first one yeah
Logan Paul yeah
I mean yeah
just go on watch the Logan Paul
three-parter that's pretty fun
um it's most fun to watch them as he
releases them because watching them in
retrospect he did a huge five or six
part series across two different
channels about rubette and Steve will do
it in the nalc boys in this uh crypto
gambling that occurs in I remember that
yeah yeah it's it's most fun to watch
them as they come out because you get to
them yeah you get to then think about
what's going to happen next and you also
get to see the reactions from people
real time as they put defensive tweets
up or whatever you can go and like have
a bit of a stalk
um I don't think Logan Paul's actually
responded to this most recently the
whole the whole impression I get from
watching it because you know you when
when did you start creating content you
see it with a kind of Creator's eye and
I'm thinking okay like he's putting a
lot of effort for this like you can
really tell he's put in the time and the
the cost and everything to to make this
video but the main thing is like he is
pissed off a lot of people he is
definitely going to be be on at least
five maybe ten people's Hit List mate so
I I know I know from from a very very
good source that he's had a ton of wild
[ __ ] happen to him from people that he's
uh investigated and he's had these
emails that say [ __ ] like uh we are
never going to stop I hope that your
kids and their grandkids are ready for
this because they're never going we're
never ever ever going to stop and you're
like [ __ ] hell and he he doesn't
monetize he doesn't do sponsors he'll
make money from AdSense and he's just
started a patreon so if you like what he
does you should go and subscribe to his
patreon because this guy pays an awful
lot of private prices to be able to do
what to everyone else is basically just
entertainment you know like exactly no
one else is gaining from Logan Paul
being taken down really I mean some
people have got money back or some
people have been sent to jail or
whatever because of the downstream
impact of particular investigations that
he's begun but yeah he's a he's a
[ __ ] coffee Zilla is great I'll
do something that I actually watched
last night and I've spoken about them
before but they've just released
something new Melody Sheep on YouTube so
they make these beautifully soundscaped
fully 3D model documentaries about what
it would be like to Journey Through the
Universe or to go to different solar
systems they did a three-part series
called alien worlds which showed what it
created an imaginary Museum of other
different types of alien life forms that
could evolve on different sorts of
planets so this would be on a planet
with really high gravity one with huge
amounts of sunlight one with tons of
oxygen this is what silicon-based life
could look like this is what artificial
intelligence could look like and it's so
beautifully designed it's absolutely
gorgeous I highly highly highly
recommend it and the most recent one
that you just did is about other
inhabitable planets that we could go and
see but it's not just
um like stock footage it's all custom
created for this soundscaped over the
the top and he'll fly you through the
world on the bottom and he'll show you a
three star the only planet we know that
orbits a three-star system in the
habitable zone and it'll try and render
what a Sunrise from three stars would
look like on this thing as he's just
talking over the top of it the one thing
that I would caveat is if you don't have
YouTube premium he [ __ ] pounds you
with ads it's every five minutes so I
highly recommend watching it on
someone's account it's got YouTube
premium but Melody sheep and the most
recent one which I think is a journey to
an alien world or something like that is
top notch
nice that's good let's round it up there
gentlemen where should people go if they
want to check out the stuff that you do
and what it is is it that you do
two things if you want to
um just get some macros from us some
calorie recommendations we have a
calculator on our website so go to
brokenfitness.com it's on the homepage
if the other side of what we do is we
help people mainly personal trainers
Fitness coaches gyms move their business
online
we summarize how we do all of that we
give you a free training that summarizes
the entire process at propanefitness.com
forward slash modern wisdom
big up what else have you got coming up
is there anything else that people
should expect from you guys soon
just more of the same
we're just always trying to slightly
improve everything we've got some stuff
we've got some exciting back end stuff
through our kind of inner circle of
clients
um that we is you know obviously a Black
Ops operation we can't can't talk about
but yeah we're going going big on
YouTube this year so have a look at us
on there cool boys I appreciate you
we're gonna go for chicken uh next week
and uh yes we are I'm looking forward to
it all right thank you
so yeah what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]